imagine if after world war
ii uh in sorting through
the ruins of berlin or some or tokyo
we had come upon uh uh
laboratories where a drug was being
produced
that so virulent that when released into
human populations
you could create a situation where uh
20 or 30 years after its introduction
into
a society of hundreds of millions
of people those people would use
this drug on an average of
six to seven hours a day being spent
under the influence
of this drug this is in fact what
television
is television
is a technological fix introduced into
this country
after world war ii and the statistics
are that the average american
average watches six and a half to seven
hours of tv a day
now just because you don't inject it
into your good right
arm doesn't mean that you don't have to
look at the consequences of this kind of
behavior
and one of the things that i'm
very interested to communicate and that
i think must be communicated to the
society
or we're never going to have a mature
dialogue
about what's going on is the fact
that the pro-psychedelic
position is an anti-drug position
and that in fact what is going on
are consciousness wars wars
designed to determine shall we or
shall we not be conscious and
how conscious shall we be
and the government is in the business
of peddling deep unconsciousness
it's utter toleration for
uh television the unregulated nature of
television's content and just the
scurviest
garbage scurrilous garbage that is
tolerated going over the media the
government's tolerance for booze
the government's tolerance for heroin
and in fact it's cynical use of heroin
to eviscerate the political intent
of the ghettos in this country the
government's tolerance of cocaine
and its use by the yuppie class in order
that the government have a source of
income
to prosecute its dirty little wars
throughout the world
you see all that the third world has to
sell is drugs
and they can sell them to the to in
into the united states and get hard
currency which they can then take to the
cia
and translate into guns and then the cia
has hard currency off the books to
pay for its wars throughout the world
this is the real hard drug cycle
that is going on in the united states
meanwhile what the psychedelics stand
for
and have always stood for is
the dissolving of unexamined habitual
behavior patterns and after all
isn't that what we object to about
hard drugs isn't that what is so
offensive about
the anything addict the heroin addict
the television addict the thing
addict is that when it comes time for
their
fix whether it be saint elsewhere
or whatever do not stand in these
people's way
you know they are going for the button
they are going for the syringe
whatever it is uh unexamined
habitual behavior that is
self-destructive and socially
destructive
is intolerable it is also the absolute
antithesis
of what psychedelics do
they break up unexamined
habitual behavior patterns they call
into question
cultural assumptions they do not dull
they do not deny they do not fill time
so they are truly psycholytic
and therefore uh truly politically
potent and one of the things that i
would like
to bring front and center
in any political dialogue about these
things
is the fact that the psychedelics are to
my mind the major force for a
serious feminizing of society feminism
got a great distance on the fact
that no one could deny or no reasonable
person could deny
that it was a good idea you know
equality of women equal pay for equal
work
caring men sharing uh child
all these things great idea and that
propelled it for its first ten years
and then it seemed to hit a brick wall
of recidivism
and and social resistance this is
because
you can't cut it with a good idea
that's not enough look at disarmament
there's a good idea that went nowhere
for a long long time
so i think feminists deep ecologists
all of these people need to overcome
the trauma and the stigma of
any reasonable effort to discuss
the role of psychedelics in society we
have essentially been
screamed into silence other than talking
to a group like this
where you know i practically know every
one of you by name
and your past history i mean this is
hardly a public gathering
so other than living room talks
like this it is it is almost
impossible to get a hearing uh
on this issue and it has to do with
uh an impoverishment of language
and a complete co-option of the
vocabulary
necessary to discuss the problem by the
other side
i mean the other side just screams drugs
drugs
and you're supposed to fall silent and
not say a word about it it's so shocking
and
unthinkable i mean i people come to my
lectures who
agree with everything i say who won't
smoke a joint in front of their children
you know because that's how powerful
the wedge is that has been driven
between parent and child in an effort to
communicate
uh what this is that actually
you know we're like jews before
auschwitz we're
affected with some kind of deep inner
guilt where we actually
agree with our oppressor on some
impossible
level so we're carrying this kind of
contradiction
inside ourselves well what ha
what needs to be done and i referred to
this earlier in a different context
is we have to evolve language
we have to make a distinction between
synthetic drugs and plants
not a not an academic distinction
not a distinction under a larger
heading but to actually say no
these things are as different as
tricycles
and doughnuts they have absolutely
nothing to do with each other
and this has been a difficult split to
make because
first of all we haven't really i think
seen how high the stakes are
and there have been hybrid cases
that spread confusion in the community
uh i'm thinking for instance of mdma
you know many people think this is a
fine
thing well it's obviously a synthetic
drug
it can be manufactured in laboratories
in doses of minions and so forth and so
on
so what about it isn't isn't it just as
good as a plant
well the answer is no for
those reasons that anything which can be
criminally syndicalized
and produced in boxcar sized lots
and sold as an unidentifiable
something in a capsule plays into the
hands of this male dominated
consumer psychology that
uh is destructive and you could also
even attack the substance on a for
itself
argument and say you know amphetamines
ultimately
are not uh constructive in the social
situation
i would like to solve the problem by
just
saying we have a cornucopia
of shamanically validated substances
that range over a wide gamut
that all the way from slight stimulation
to uh unimaginably
intense psychedelic breakthrough
and all of these compounds have been
used over
tens of millennia they are use proven we
know they don't cause miscarriages or
tumors or chromosomal breakage because
they are part of the legacy
of our history on this planet
so then it isn't so much a matter
of uh seeking
through pharmacology uh
ever more and varied kinds of
consciousness altering
things it's more about trying to get
back
to our roots and trying to get
the most benign plant person
relationships possible
put in place and i think
that in the indoles
we have this and that this is a good way
to think of it
because it's it can be understood by our
critics
because they are reductionists and
materialists
so if we say to them the indoles
are the special category we will save 90
of what we want to save and exclude 95
of what we wish to exclude because the
indoles
are the lysorgimides
the beta-carbolines the tryptamines
and the boga alkaloids
and i think that that is a sufficient
spectrum with their antimers and
antimers cogeners and so forth
that we can do what we need to do
politically and for our own spiritual
group
and remain within that
small men and try to create
a redefining of what these things are
[Music]
foreign